REVERBERATE AROUND THE COUNTRY
WERE GLAD YOUR SAVINGS BEING
WITH US.
TONIGHT YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
LEFT-WING VIOLENCE THE SAME
MEDICAL GROUP OFFERING BOUNTIES
OF ANY CONSERVATIVES NOW
TEMPTING TO SHUT DOWN THE
CONGRESSIONAL BASEBALL GAME NO
REPUBLICAN DESERVES PEACE EVER
AGAIN SENATOR ROMP PAUL IS NO
STRANGER HIMSELF TO VIOLENT
AGITATORS HAS BEEN ATTACKED AT
LEAST TWICE INCLUDING ONE
INSTANCE RIGHT AFTER THE RNC
CONVENTION CENTER AND HIS WIFE
SURROUNDED BY FAR LEFT LUNATICS
AND RIDERS BARELY GOT OUT OF
THERE WITH HIS LIFE INCIDENT
WITH THE NEIGHBOR IS KENTUCKY
SENATOR ROMP ALL I KNOW
WASHINGTON, D.C., IS NOT FAR OFF
FROM NEW YORK IS HER LACK OF
WILLINGNESS TO PROSECUTE PEOPLE
THAT ARE VIOLENT AT LEAST IN
KENTUCKY THEY GOT THE TAX YOU AS
I UNDERSTAND PEER PRICE RIGHT?
>> ULTIMATELY A CLINTON JUDGE
GAVE HIM ONE MONTH WHICH IS WHAT
YOU MIGHT GET FOR SHOPLIFTING
CAME BACK LATER AND ANOTHER
DEMOCRAT APPOINTED JUDGE PREFER
APPOINTED JUDGE GAVE HIM ANOTHER
EIGHT MONTHS SO HE HAD NINE
MONTHS BUT WE STILL HAVE OUR
MAJOR NEWSPAPER WITH THE
LOUISVILLE COURIER WRITING OP-ED
SAYING THAT IT WAS JUSTIFIED
THEY TACKLE ME WAS JUSTIFIED AND
THAT IT DESERVED IT BECAUSE I'M
SOMEHOW A PROVOCATIVE PERSON.
MY INTERVIEWING AND MY STYLE OF
INTERVIEWING IS PROVOCATIVE AND
THEREFORE REGISTER VIOLENCE.
THERE ARE STILL SAYING THAT IN
THE NEWSPAPER ONE OF OUR
NEWSPAPERS EMPLOYED A YOUNG MAN
WHO TRIED TO ASSASSINATE THE
MAYOR CANDIDATE OF LOUISVILLE HE
GOT TWO DAYS IN PRISON AND HE
WAS RELEASED THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER BILE AMOUNT AFTER TWO
DAYS AND HE WORKED FOR THE
LOUISVILLE COURIER WE NOW HAVE A
NEW WRITER FOR THE LOUISVILLE
COURIER WHO'S BEEN ARRESTED FOR
VIOLENT ASSAULT AND NOW HE IS
WRITING THE VIOLENCE AGAINST ME
WAS JUSTIFIED, BUT HE WAS
PREVIOUSLY BEEN CONVICTED OF
ASSAULT TOO.
THE ARE EGGING THIS ON EVERYONE
AT THE END WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE UP.
THE VIOLENT PEOPLE NEED TO BE
PUT AWAY FOR AS LONG AS WE CAN
PUT THEM AWAY.
>> Hannity: AND REAL-TIME ON
THE RADIO JANUARY 6TH I CONDEMN
WHAT WAS HAPPENING I CONDEMNED
IT THAT NIGHT ON THE SHOW AND
YET IN THE SUMMER OF 2020 YOUR
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES WERE
EITHER COMPLETELY SILENT BECAUSE
IT WAS THEIR BASE THAT WAS
INVOLVED WITH THE LOOTING AND
THE WRITING IN THE ARSON ATTACKS
ON POLICE THOUSANDS OF COPS
ENTERED DOES INSTEAD OF DOING
SOME PROPERTY DAMAGE 574 RIOTS
VERY FEW PROSECUTIONS IN THIS
CASE EVEN KNOW WE HAVE A WEALTH
OF EVIDENCE OR LECTURING US ON
THE NEED TO SAFELY AND SECURITY
ON THE ONE RIOT WARRANTEE
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST THE 507 FOR
OTHER RIOTS?
WHERE'S THAT COMMITTEE.
>> A WOMAN IN HER 60s WHO'S
GETTING CANCER TREATMENT WANDERS
INTO THE CAPITAL DURING ALL OF
THIS WANDERS OUT DOESN'T HARM
ANYONE IS NOT INVOLVED WITH
VIOLENCE AND SHE GETS LONGER IN
PRISON THE PEOPLE TRYING TO A
CASTANEDA CANDIDATE ARE JUST
AMAZING WHAT WERE DOING AND WHO
WERE LETTING OFF OF THIS BUT
ULTIMATELY THIS CAN BECOME A DAY
OF RECKONING WHEN THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY CRIME
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS THOSE
IN POOR NEIGHBORHOODS AND THOSE
WHO ARE MINORITIES ONE DAY
THEY'RE GONNA RISE UP AND SAY
WE'VE HAD ENOUGH THE DEMOCRATS
ARE NOT PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN,
KIDS ARE DYING AT THE BUS STOP.
KIDS ARE DYING ON THE SUBWAY.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE ABOUT
YOUR KIDS AND IT CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN DECADE AFTER DECADE
THERE'S GONNA BE A DAY THAT
PEOPLE ARE GONNA WAKE UP AND SAY
WE'VE HAD ENOUGH WE'RE GONNA
VOTE FOR LAW AND ORDER AND LEE
IS THE CANDIDATE.
I THINK THERE'S A CHANCE WE HAVE
THE PEOPLE IN JAIL.
I THINK THAT IS COMING I DIG A
BIG PUSH BACK IS COMING ON A LOT
OF ISSUES INCLUDING WE NEED LAW
AND WE NEED ORDER WE NEED SAFETY
AND SECURITY TO PURSUE
HAPPINESS.
PARENTS WANT READING, WRITING,
MATH, AND SCIENCE, THEY DON'T
WANT LET'S SEE WHATEVER
POLITICAL AGENDA IS BEING RAMMED
DOWN KIDS THROATS.
I ALSO WANT LOWER GAS PRICES AND
ELIMINATION OF THE INFLATION
RECORD HIGH THAT WE